another episode of loki has arrived
bringing with it some twists a
long-awaited cameo and even some
unexpected romance
what does it all mean where will our
favorite god of mischief be heading next
here's the ending of loki episode 4
explained
the immediate question coming out of
episode three was how loki and sylvie
were going to escape death in the face
of an apocalypse on lamentus
that kind of life or death situation
brings out some real honesty in both of
the two gods of mischief
faced with the possibility of being
crushed to death the two grow closer and
sylvie opens up about why she's trying
to dismantle the time variance authority
as it turns out ravana ren slayer is the
hunter who originally snatched sylvie
from asgard when she was just a young
girl which we see at the beginning of
the episode
the trauma of being ripped away from her
home has given silvi the goal of
destroying the tva
in any case sylvie definitely has a bone
to pick with ravana herself
blaming the tva chief for forcing her to
grow up through the ends of a thousand
worlds
as loki and sylvia wait their doom the
two variants have a brief
tender moment in the base of armageddon
with sylvia affectionately touching
loki's arm
however when two variants interact like
that it creates a new timeline branch
which alerts mobius and the rest of the
tva to their location so they can
retrieve them
[Music]
one of the most surprising moments of
the episode was a delightful cameo from
lady sith who hasn't appeared in the mcu
since
thor the dark world unless you count a
2015 episode of marvel's agents of
shield
although her role in the episode is only
a minor one it forces loki to take a
closer look at himself mobius traps loki
in a time loop where sif repeatedly
beats him up in asgard for cutting off
her hair as a joke
sure the physical beating is torturous
but it's not the true purpose of the
loot
rather it's what she says to the
trickster that slowly chips away at
loki's resolve
i hope you know you deserve to be alone
and you always will be
the god of mischief has always seen
himself as a loner and an outsider even
though he was considered family by the
likes of thorin odin
obviously this version of the character
didn't get the original story arc after
the events of the avengers that made him
realize that he truly has a family but
this time luke is clearly setting the
asgardian up to realize that he doesn't
want to live like that anymore
additionally loki is falling for sylvie
something mobius finds hilarious in his
interrogation scene
what a incredible seismic narcissist
you felt for yourself indeed loki's in
love with himself a development that
definitely doesn't seem like it will end
well
however loki's conversation with mobius
leads to the god of mischief trying to
convince mobius that everyone at the tva
are actually variants whose memories
have been erased
loki's insistence that timekeepers are
kidnapping variants and wiping their
memories to work for the tva pushes
mobius to look into his claims in fact
it says a lot about the impact loki has
had on the tva analyst that he's started
to take him seriously
mobius and loki have struck up a genuine
friendship even if that friendship is
based on the two of them trying to
outsmart each other at every turn
it's that friendship that makes mobius
sneak a look at ravana's tempat after
she refuses to explain what really
happened to hunter c20
which allows him to discover that loki
was right about the tva
this means ravana is covering up the
timekeeper's deceit
obviously ravana doesn't want this
information to become public knowledge
so when mobius starts wondering aloud
about what his life was like before
being a cosmic bureaucrat she orders a
hunter to prune him
hopefully this isn't the last we see of
mobius
ever since the first episode of loki
fans have suspected that the timekeepers
aren't even real
largely because we haven't seen them in
action at all in the series so far
but in a surprise twist ravana takes the
two loki variants to meet the trio of
space lizards
leading to an interesting conversation
between the tba chief and sylvie
after everything silvia is still
desperate for answers about why her life
was thrown into ruin because of the tva
the show still hasn't explained what
nexus event made the tva go after sylvie
and ravana isn't about to open up about
that just yet
instead she brushes silvie's question
off saying she doesn't remember why they
were sent after her which visibly
crushes and enrages sylvie
after an atmospheric battle in the
timekeeper's smoky chamber the series
reveals the three aliens running the tva
are actually androids so clearly someone
else entirely is pulling the tva strings
but who's really behind the tva
regardless the variants have proved that
perhaps a dash of chaos is exactly what
the multiverse needs
they're even on the cusp of confessing
their feelings for one another a
possibility seemingly ruined when ravana
prunes loki right in front of sylvie
but wait there's more the series first
mid-credit scene reveals that loki might
not be dead
once again the trickster cheats death in
the mcu and the asgardian wakes up in
what looks like a ruined version of new
york asking if he's in hell
in response a dramatic voice replies
not yet but you will be unless you come
with us
and that's when the show's biggest twist
yet is revealed introducing us to four
more loki variants
is this new world filled with other dead
loki's or is it home to countless pruned
variants from across the multiverse
hopefully episode 5 will have more
answers
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite
mcu shows are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one